die kämpfe sind vermutlich die letzten
grösseren gefechte im syrischen
bürgerkrieg der wiederaufbau des landes
und die rückkehr von flüchtlingen
geraten daher verstärkt in den
mittelpunkt denn die verwüstungen sind
groß und die bevölkerung situation hat
sich radikal verändert heute in vechta
kompakt rückkehr vom syrischen
flüchtlingen
[Musik]
der bürgerkrieg in syrien ist soweit
entschieden aber das land hat sich seit
2011 dramatisch verändert bis zu 500.000
menschen wurden getötet mehr als die
hälfte der bevölkerung lebt nicht mehr
am ursprünglichen ort von den 21
millionen syrern sieht mehr als sechs
millionen innerhalb syriens und ebenso
viele ins ausland geflohen aufgrund der
kampfhandlungen um idlib dem letzten
rückzugsraum der islamistischen kämpfer
mussten im frühjahr 2009 10 noch einmal
mehr als 300.000 menschen in den norden
der provinz fliehen
die türkei hat die grenzen geschlossen
syrische flüchtlinge haben in 125
ländern asyl erhalten
laut uno sind allein in den
nachbarländern an die fünf millionen
registriert in europa konnten knapp
700.000 schülerinnen und schüler
zuflucht finden
am meisten hat die türkei aufgenommen
annähernd dreieinhalb millionen im
libanon dürften sich mehr als eine
million befinden jordanien spricht von
1,3 millionen
im irak sind mehr als 250.000 in ägypten
etwa 130000 deutschland hat 500.000
aufgenommen schweden mehr als 103.000
österreich knapp 44.000 und die
niederlande 30.900 rund eine million
syrische kinder wurden seit 2011 im
ausland geboren ihre staatszugehörigkeit
ist ungeklärt
nach acht jahren krieg stellt sich nun
vermehrt die frage können die schüler
wieder in ihre heimatorte zurückkehren
und werden sie es auch tun
vier aspekte sind dabei entscheidend
erstens die zerstörte infrastruktur
im krieg wurde vieles vernichtet die
kosten für den wiederaufbau werden auf
300 milliarden bis 1,2 billionen dollar
geschätzt vielerorts sind
gesundheitseinrichtungen die
trinkwasser- und stromversorgung sowie
schulen großteils zerstört nahezu die
hälfte aller krankenhäuser und erst
versorgungseinrichtungen ist entweder
nicht oder nur eingeschränkt
funktionsfähig ein viertel der häuser
wurde beschädigt zehn prozent sind
komplett zerstört
sprengfallen und nicht explodierte
munition gefährden mehr als zehn
millionen schülerinnen und schüler vor
allem kindern
zweitens die sicherheitslage die
rückkehr nach syrien ist riskant
menschen aus gegenden der opposition
werden häufig als verräter
oppositionelle oder terroristen
eingestuft viele befürchten auf den
fahndungslisten des geheimdienstes zu
stehen und nach ihrer rückkehr verfolgt
zu werden
willkürliche verhaftungen und das
verschwinden von personen steigern diese
ängste männern zwischen 18 und 42 jahren
droht außerdem die zwangsrekrutierung
durch das syrische militär
drittens rechtliche rahmenbedingungen
2018 wurde ein gesetz verabschiedet das
syrern im in und ausland ein jahr zeit
gibt ihr eigentum anzumelden
anderenfalls würden die rechte verfallen
noch aus dem jahr 2012 gibt es ein anti
terror gesetz dass meinungsfreiheit und
unabhängige medien unterbindet das
syrische regime scheint generell kein
interesse an der rückkehr von
flüchtlingen zu haben
dagegen sollen alle die ausgeharrt haben
belohnt werden und viertens die
situation in den aufnahmeländern alle
staaten der region möchten möglichst
rasch viele flüchtlinge zurückschicken
besonders der libanon leidet unter der
großen zahl die türkei und jordanien
sind bestrebt syrer und ihre familien
zur rückkehr in ihr heimatland zu
bewegen
in europäischen staaten wird zwar
einerseits eine rückkehr gefordert
andererseits aber angesichts der
verhältnisse in syrien
die zumutbarkeit stark bezweifelt zur
aktuellen situation
es sieht zwar einige hundert tausend
syrer aus dem in und ausland wieder
zurückgekehrt eine große rückkehr welle
ist aber nicht zu erkennen
bisher hat präsident assad keine
zugeständnisse gemacht oder gar anreize
gesetzt bereits 2017 hatte auf die in
seinen augen positiven effekte von krieg
flucht und vertreibung hingewiesen
seiner meinung nach sei für ihn nun eine
homogenere und gesündere gesellschaft
die skepsis und ängste der syrischen
flüchtlinge im ausland hinsichtlich
ihrer rückkehr sind daher verständlich
viele europäische politiker fordern
deshalb eine politische lösung des
syrien konflikts und der vermittlung der
uno bevor flüchtlinge zurückgeschickt
werden ein kurzer ausblick in den
ländern der region wird vermutlich der
druck auf syrer und ihre familien
steigen das land wieder richtung heimat
zu verlassen
erfahrungsgemäß gehen jene zurück die
sich trotz aller umstände hoffnungen auf
eine bessere zukunft machen keine
perspektiven am derzeitigen ort sehen
oder sie kann ein aufenthalt nicht mehr
leisten können
es ist aber unrealistisch in absehbarer
zeit eine massive rückwanderung
syrischer flüchtlinge aus europa zu
erwarten